[Music]
so guys humbly we've landed in Samoa
it's a small tiny island the middle of
the Pacific Ocean we don't know anyone
here we have no contact whatsoever and
we're looking for someone called dr.
Stanley we just saw him in an article on
life
sorry come did I see you in the article
is your name dr. Stanley we come from
with our organization how is the Dow and
some more is they're very active being
done a lot it is a one-man army
operation I am doing all the work and
trying to bring people in so we're here
to help you chef
if there's anything we can do we want to
start the dollar with you we want to
bring our Jesus exhibition in sha Allah
never seen an exhibition like this
before
I am excited Allah knows what's how my
heart is beating with happiness
this is my hot spot PHP my certificate
signor William Blackstone yeah this
school is day one thing this is visually
great length of in shorin-ryu sorry guys
so basically we have now in Shambhala
put the ADA on TV one which is the
biggest TV channel in some or 90% of the
population watches it we've got a
newspaper ad down humble MA and now
we're gonna go back to a second TV
channel that's entertainment this is
mostly sports and stuff okay in a
station with me we've got a member from
the Islam of war he's traveled all the
way from from the UK there's only one
mosque in the entire country so we
thought why not just open it up for the
summer ones they think
see what happened inside you know yes oh
I I have been very intrigued about that
okay so this is like bowing
[Music]
of all the profits we believe Jesus
still alive
you believe him as a quick messenger we
believe Mary is the greatest woman in
Islam
she quite shocked about everything oh
jesus son of mary did you say two people
worship me and my mother instead of god'
ash-hadu anla ilaha illaallah it is said
that some more is the best-kept secret
in the world and maybe it's true Allah
creates an opening for you to come
religion came to this country from
missionaries from London now you have
come again to follow up and correct so
this is all the work of your donors now
that that dower has started don't allow
it to stop so click the button and
donate now and help us to continue the
dower in Samoa and across the world and
please don't forget to share this video
so people can learn about this amazing
brother
[Music]
you
[Music]